als jugendlicher war samu haber in
dubiose geschäfte verwickelt
er arbeitete für eine windige
immobilienfirma in spanien die gezielt
touristen abzockt ich hatte krude
gedanken und wollte keine verantwortung
übernehmen und ich habe die mechanismen
von solch einer firma so weit weg von zu
hause nicht verstanden und das war im
jahr 1998 ich habe alles geglaubt was
sie mir gesagt haben und klar ich hätte
etwas cleverer sein müssen aber ich war
jung und doof und ich wollte einfach im
paradies leben als gestandener musiker
kann der sunrise avenue sänger und des
jura heute offen über seine dunkle
vergangenheit sprechen
einige bezeichnen mich als ehemaligen
verbrecher aber zum glück sind meine
heimat finnland und deutschland länder
in denen man eine neue chance bekommt
wenn man für fehler einsteht
es waren schwere zeiten ich habe da noch
eingesehen dass ich ein idiot war als
ich jung war trotz seiner dunklen
vergangenheit stand die musik immer im
mittelpunkt seines lebens meine dunklen
gedanken tauchen auf wenn ich am klavier
sitze und ich mich eine melodie hingebe
dann kann ich richtig ins dunkle gehen
aber ansonsten würde ich sagen dass ich
ziemlich sonnig bin und optimistisch
nicht mal die korona krisen im team als
musiker die freude am beruf
er hofft dass er nächstes jahr wieder
auf tour gehen kann
wir mussten die tour verschieben und wir
hoffen dass sie nächstes jahr
stattfindet es liegt nicht in unserer
hand
es finden keine events statt keine
buchlesungen wir müssen mit diesen
umständen leben mein großvater sagte
immer es ist zu spät zu weinen wenn du
schon in die hosen geschissen hast und
du kannst es nicht ändern
du sitzt dann einfach mit der scheiße in
der user das ist das dümmste was ich
jemals vor einer kamera gesagt habe
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren